have a look at part two again again it's
intimidating but there's a big clue what
is this stuff what are these it is a
sequence what it's actually a series
he's actually adding up some things but
what is that what is that notation this
for example that this is binomials and
this is another way of writing this this
is a binomial coefficient now have a
look it's not just one binomial
coefficient you got a whole bunch of
them you go from zero all the way up
until n why don't you go all the way up
until end let's think about this way if
I gave you a you know 1 plus X cubed
right
the by now if you want coefficient so
you're gonna get out of that from
Pascal's triangle I'm gonna be n naught
and then n 1 and then n 2 and then
you'll end within 3 right wherein
actually happens to be 3 in this case
right
3 3 3 3 because of course you can't have
3 C 4 cos like Cartesian form two
instead of three things okay we have
threes all the way at the top and three
at the end because because the powers
through perish thing he got ends at the
top a whole bunch of them
why will I have ends at the top
because I'm extending something to the
power of M yes okay now where a lot of
students sort of fell down is they felt
like and I hope you recognize this is
something we need to overcome you look
at a question and you classify it and
you think oh this is a question about
that but these are clearly linked right
so you should see these ends at the arm
I can treat this not like I can't just
turn this into from rectangular form
into polar form I can treat this as just
a regular binomial expansion it's just
that that second thing happens to be
imaginary okay so let's do that right
this is part to consider I considered
this before and I dictum obviously
Ramona right but now I'm going to do
binomial theorem on it okay
so what would the very first term be
zero the next one is gonna be and one
but now that I get to the next bit and I
it comes along for the ride do you agree
that and then two and I'm gonna have
long enough to eyes on it I squared okay
now usually to establish a pattern three
times is enough right like if you get
three terms of an AP or GPU I know
everything about this now okay for
reasons they'll become clear shortly I'm
gonna put a couple of extra terms on I'm
gonna go and three and four I think
that'll be enough for me now this is the
first five terms what's the last term
yeah very good on the and whatever that
happens to be okay now I can do a little
work on this before I leave it and think
about the other one it's conjugate okay
there's a whole bunch of ice here that
can be canceled out do you agree okay
these first two they just kind of sit
there right what about the next one so
yeah I squared by definition is minus 1
right so that's kind of cool now there's
a I squared here as well isn't there so
therefore it's - but there's still one I
left over yeah okay then I get to this
one and it's just plus 1 right do you
see why I wrote a few extra terms now
because usually three is enough to
establish a patent but here the pan
takes longer it goes this look at the
signs plus a plus minus a minus right
there i buy i buy and so on okay
the next one but the next one be scary
plus if I were to write it down I think
it would be plus and five I'm right
because there's actually five eyes there
but four of them have just sort of
collapsed into one dot dot plus that you
okay with that okay now there's actually
one more thing I can do to this it's one
more thing I can do this in what's in
look at the question again
yeah ends not just anything and it's
divisible by 4 4 1 2 3
sorry 1 2 3 4 4 right and then 1 2 3 4
and then 1 2 3 4 and then eventually
this guy is gonna be one of the fourth
ones right so what's gonna happen to
this it's gonna be one just one isn't it
right because I'm I to that it could be
is 4 8 or 12 or 16 whatever number eyes
it's gonna be it will cancel out so in
fact though what I see I can do on this
line is all of these guys are all the
same but I know that the very last term
is going to be top it up and em the
reason why is because and is a multiple
of 4 I'm just running out of space that
might be brave you do okay you notice
that